the cloud on air live webinars from
Google Cloud we host these webinars
every Tuesday and my name is Chris
kleban and today I'll be talking about
cloud GPUs you could ask questions
anytime on the platform then we have
Google Earth standing by to answer them
so let's get started
so if you're on the audience live or
watching the recording let me just spend
a couple of minutes talking about what a
GPU is in case you don't know so as this
picture shows GPU started with gaming my
mom would play Frogger back when I was a
little baby trying to get that frog
across the road or over the river I
played a Nintendo Super Mario Brothers
going down the pipes and the secret
warps and my son now plays minecraft on
his xbox with his friends and over the
time of these generations of gaming in
my family the graphics have gotten
better and better and those graphics
have gotten better thanks to a little
hardware chip called the GPU
these GPUs are everywhere they're in
your cell phones and your laptops and
your game consoles and your PC's under
your desk and for data centers and cloud
what we do is we take out that small GPU
and make a really big one and that big
GPU you'll see a picture of three of
them stacked up on one on top of the
other
we put them in servers and like GPUs do
for gaming GPUs and the data center do
for computing gaming needs lots of
things drawn on the screen in real time
scientific research needs lots of math
done as fast as quickly as possible so
how does GPU acceleration compete work
well you take some application code it
could be written in Python C++
tensorflow anything you want and all
that code mostly runs on the CPU the CPU
does things sequential a write one after
the time there's some if-then logic but
what if your application code has a
bunch of math it wants to do instead of
doing it one at a time and taking a long
time what if you do that math all at the
same time so the code in the green the
math part let's ship that to the GPU
that could do it fast let's multiply ten
numbers together 100 a million a billion
get it done quickly put the results back
to the CPU and in essence that's GPU
accelerated compute together it's
speeding up your applications so what
kind of workloads are we talking about
here the first ones machine learning
right GPUs are all about machine
learning in AI of these days there's two
types of workloads training and
inference training is about building the
artificial intelligence the logic
birthing it if you will right it's not a
person saying well if the car sees a
human you better hit the brakes you
better turn left you better turn right
it's not about that at all it's about
putting a bunch of data synthetic or
actual through some logic having the
computer system learn what the right
behaviors are or learn how to define a
cat in a photo right and build that AI
intelligence and then machine learning
inference is once you have that
intelligence it's doing something with
it I think Google photos is this great
for example and it does search right I
have a hundred thousand pictures of my
kids right but it's really hard to find
the picture that I'm looking for well in
Google photos I could just click click
the picture of my son Aiden type in the
word beach I know it predicts and finds
really quickly with accelerated Hardware
all the pictures that I'm looking for
and the user doesn't want to wait five
minutes ten minutes to find that they
want it automatically and that's what
inference is using the AI to do
something GPU acceleration is also great
for HPC right or high-performance
computing workloads here we're talking
about weather simulations engineering
seismic analysis a bunch of things that
typically run on grid systems and then
there's a classic visualization case it
could be gaming or it could be a working
professional that might have a
workstation under their desk with
expensive GPU hardware right and maybe
the cloud GPU is a better approach there
so those are a few workloads done by
GPUs so let's talk about one of the
first 99 problems but a cloud GPU eight
one the first problem is about access to
compute power so we asked a bunch of AI
researchers and experts what are the
things that contribute to all the AI
advances 80% of them said one of the
main reasons was just access to raw high
power compute it's amazing right it's
not necessarily that we're learning to
do new things it's just access to more
power that's really driving things
forward on the other hand we asked
people coming to tensorflow organization
which is an open source machine learning
algorithm creation framework we asked
them what are the problems you have with
building AI and a large majority of them
said well we just don't have access to
compute we need so here we have this
problem access to compute drives
innovation people trying to innovate
don't have access to compute so there
has to be a better way
so according to an article on time.com
if you wanted to buy a supercomputer
right one of the largest computers in
the world it might cost you a hundred
million dollars or 250 million dollars
that's a lot of money on the top 500
this which lists the biggest
supercomputers in the world back in 2008
the number one supercomputer had a
thousand 456 teraflops that's a lot of
power but imagine if you're a researcher
working on a really important business
problem like I want to get some
recommendations for online shopping or I
want to innovate with self-driving cars
but let's say you went to your CTO your
director and said can I please buy a
supercomputer for 100 million dollars
right you'd be laughed at not because
the business problem isn't real just
spending that capital upfront crazy so
let's talk about the alternative let's
say we take a thousand K 80 GPUs on
Google cloud and created a cluster for
an hour using regular on-demand pricing
it would cost you about $500 for those
thousand GPUs to run an experiment to
see if what you're working on will do
the thing you need for your business and
if you use something called preemptable
GPUs which we'll talk about later you
could even drive down that cost even
more to 250 an hour or less so now let's
say you have that same conversation with
your IT director who manages the budget
and say I want to solve this really
important business problem I want to do
some quick innovation test to see if
this is gonna work do you go mind if I
spin up this cluster a super compute
worth of power spend 250 bucks well
you'll be laughed out again but not
because they're gonna say no they're
gonna say of course just go do that so
that's the power of Google Cloud right
bringing new scale of compute and let's
go ahead and show you a demo of what it
looks like to spin up a cluster of
computing instances so what I'm showing
you now this is the Google Cloud console
Google Cloud if you go over to the top
left you'll see there's a lot of
services here
there's VM instances instance groups and
what we are we're in the compute engine
this is all about infrastructure as a
service and well I'll show you is how to
do an instance group and when an
instance group is is a logical entity of
infrastructure it could be one server it
could be a thousand it could be ten
thousand and you use those instance
groups to run a series of workloads
right you can scale it up scale it down
you could have Google Auto scale it
based on load so to create an instance
group click on a button give it a name
we're gonna call this cloud on air five
we are going to pick a single zone
because we only care about doing this
experiment we're gonna pick a region
plenty of regions to choose from we'll
pick Asia East one Asia East one a as a
zone and there's two kind of instance
groups management's a group and an
unmanaged in this group management is
group we could do a lot of things for we
could do rolling updates Road role your
code foe would roll it back we could do
auto scaling load balancing and for this
demo we'll pick this for instance
templates right this is where you go
ahead and pick a template to create a
virtual machine and here you're gonna
pick the size of the VM the shape and
all of that so we're gonna go ahead and
customize an instance template we'll
pick the number of CPUs we want anywhere
from 1 to 96 we'll pick them out of
memory we want and we'll go look at GPUs
in this case we want one GPU per VM and
since this is a gem oh let's just do one
core and let's do four gigabytes of RAM
let's do one GPU let's give it an
operating system here there's plenty to
choose from application images OS images
custom images in this case we'll just
pick and Mbutu with a standard disk or
an SSD disk maybe this is machine
learning so we want to go fast and we'll
pick a 10 gigabyte SSD back disk we'll
save this in
image or this template called instance
template one so now that we have this
template all we need to do is create a
thousand copies of this so we'll go down
to auto scaling will turn this off
because we want to create a static
cluster and for this demo we'll just put
number of instances as one for now and
we'll hit create so now we're Google
clouds creating this logical group in
Asia with one VM it's going to give each
of those VMs an IP address and SSH key
it's going to secure it in your own
private network it's going to have
Nvidia drivers installed with CUDA
depending on your application you can go
ahead and pre install your application
like tensorflow or whatever you need if
you click on the logic group you'll see
that there's one instance and installed
it has an IP address an external you can
go over to the details tab and look at
what kind of instance template was used
whether or not auto scaling was on you
can go over to monitoring to see things
like how much CPU utilization your
clusters using or the size of the
cluster over time and so on and so forth
if you'd go to the instance you can go
in and SSH to the instance that was just
created and since we want a
supercomputer right we want a thousand
VMs all at once we want to run that
experiment really quickly super compute
power right we don't want one
right we want a thousand so I'm gonna
change the number of instances to a
thousand and I'm gonna hit save and now
what Google cloud is gonna do it's gonna
spin up and it's going to create a
thousand instances all of them with the
infrastructure I need the applications
installed and I'm gonna be able to use
that for my workloads it's gonna take a
few minutes and for the sake of time
we'll keep going but just like that you
get a supercomputer in the matter of
minutes for an affordable price so let's
switch back
so we talked a little bit about scale we
talked about GPUs while they're
important
now let's double-click on AI a little
bit businesses no longer have the option
just to skip artificial intelligence and
machine learning
right it's innovate or die how can I
differentiate myself from the
competitors how could I reduce costs how
can I do something new
how can I disrupt in an industry so
these are things that are happening now
and every organization around the world
is starting to think about it and
implementing it and who better to
partner with on artificial intelligence
than Google Google has been an AI
company from birth google search is well
known for giving the best results wham-o
self-driving cars were working on that
technology to bring that to the masses
I've already talked about Google photos
and how that uses they are I
particularly also loved YouTube right my
kids will borrow my phone use YouTube
all the time and now when I pick up
YouTube
I get recommendations for things like do
you want to see Daniel Tiger you know I
don't but you know thank I know my kids
do and we built in these artificial
intelligence features into our products
it's a blue graph that you're seeing on
the page this is showing you the number
of projects internal at Google that have
the Google brain AI model built into
them as you can see exponential growth
with a number of things internally that
we're doing with artificial intelligence
but Y partner with Google on ML right
with GPUs and otherwise we already
talked about scale we've talked about
how easy it is to go get yourself a
supercomputer we talked about a speed
and why GPUs are really important right
it's about doing your compute faster if
you do what you need to do on CPUs it's
gonna take you a really long time for
these workloads and you don't want to
wait so why don't offload two GPUs we
showed you the k80 which is a few
generations old GPU by now but we also
have the P 100 and the V 100 newer
generations that are faster if you want
ultra-high performance we've also come
out with a cloud TPU this is an ASIC or
a little chip just like a GPU but it's
specific for machine there
so if you're running in tensorflow you
could write ml code on cpu GPU or TPU
and if you pick Google Cloud you can be
rest assured that we'll always have the
fastest infrastructure for you
regardless of whatever you want to
choose so if you don't want to deal with
infrastructure we also have a suite of
services in AI let's talk about the
quality of her AI models if you're just
a programmer running Python and building
web apps and you don't want to worry
about doing your own HP C or ml clusters
we have ai services packed by api's
google image recognition translation
video analysis all of these that are
just an API call away do a prediction
for you with super high quality or maybe
you do want a custom ml model we have a
brand new service called Auto ml and I
really love this this is machine
learning creating machine learning one
of our customers customers Disney they
came and they said we have these Disney
products and we want our customers to be
able to search online for the right
product and we want to use Google
expertise to build this image
recognition system can you please use
auto ml to do it and they have very
smart programmers they came in they
picked up our API service created a
machine learning custom ologist for them
very quickly and were able to launch
that into their shopping experience so
machine learning at Google cloud it's a
bunch of things all together on the
bottom layer we've already talked about
hardware accelerators like GPU and GPUs
and why they make it faster and how you
could save time and money by using them
but it's also as the left shows about
the data we have very large object
storage where you can put in your raw
files we have bigquery for databases and
analytics we have data proc which does a
dupe and spark clusters for HP seed silo
workloads but then there's also up the
stack from the hardware we have the
kubernetes engine right this is a
cluster of servers that run containers
first-class and GPUs are integrated into
our kubernetes engine where you can go
ahead and run your HPC and mo workloads
out of kubernetes cluster with
containers or let's say you don't want
to deal with the infrastructure
containers of VMs we have cloud ml
engine also powered by GPUs
Clow and dungeon is you want to do some
training or inference ml workloads but
you don't want to create the
infrastructure so you just deal with our
api's or UI or g cloud and you say i
would like to do a tensorflow job and
train a model please give me the results
and use this data or I would like to do
predictions and inference workloads with
the model I just trained right but it's
a managed service and abstract that
complexity away from you we also have
kaggle which is a great community of ml
experts right and they also do
competitions for ml I myself did a
competition right in kaggle and I
learned all about how to code and use
tensor flow it was a competition for
detecting distracted drivers it would be
a picture of a driver and some would be
looking and paying attention and so I'm
gonna be drinking a soda or talking on
the cell phone and you had a write code
that would create the ml model on a GPU
and try to figure out if that person's
distracted and company is used Kaggle to
kind of create AI for their companies
but people like me that maybe aren't
experts or were experts could now go to
Cavill and ask this community hey I'm
trying to do this how do I get over this
problem and the community helps guide
you so it's a great resource a
tensorflow we talked about a little bit
it's an open-source ml framework that
anyone could use on Prem or on Google
Cloud and it works on CPUs GPUs teepees
you name it and another new project was
called Kubb flow this is tensorflow in
essence right on kubernetes clusters and
it's open source so you could run an
on-prem you can run on Google Cloud or
wherever you want it's a brand new
project backed by Google so all together
right from the GPU up machine learning
in Google Cloud because the data
services and the high-end services we
think we're really a great partner we
want to work with you on this so let's
switch context let's look at another
problem on-premise deployments they take
time maybe today you have an existing
cluster of servers with GPU workloads or
you're considering hey for my new
project do I want to go do it on pram or
use the cloud
well there's a lot of problems on the
sheet right ordering the stuff securing
and installing the pieces finding
collocation and you can do all that it
might be the right choice for you
alternatively you can use Google Cloud
I'll just talk a little bit about the
benefits of using GPU computing on
Google cloud first is the infrastructure
we've been doing this a long time right
building servers data centers innovating
on power and cooling and by choosing
Google Cloud you get to take the
advantage of using that infrastructure
large-scale compute some of the biggest
networks fiber-optic backbone great data
center networks high-end security high
performance storage fast provisioning I
showed you a demo earlier right where
you can create a cluster put in one VM
change the number to a thousand in a few
minutes later there you go super
computer security is built in before
Google launched cloud we've always been
cared about security and privacy and
user trust and the cloud has been lucky
to adopt a lot of the same technology we
use to protect Google's other services
so it's too much to list here but we
feel that we are a security leader in
cloud and by choosing Google cloud for
your GPU workload you'd get that built
in and that lower capital right you
don't have to go spend 250 million on an
HPC cluster just spin up some capacity
and run your workloads let's get a
little technical right there metal
performance on GPUs the VM is
virtualized but the GPUs are through
PCIe pass-through mode and what that
means is the VM has raw access to the
PCI Hardware bus and you have bare metal
performance for your GPU accelerator
that applies for all of our models the K
80 be 100 and P 100 another piece I
really like about Google Cloud is the
flexibility and customization you're not
locked into a strict ratio I want a
small amount of CPU memory in GPU or
have to get a big amount of all of those
things and you just picking sizes but
instead you can create a custom VM shape
for you what amount of CPU do you need
for your exact workload how much host
memory what type of GPU KTP 100 V 100
how many GPUs and what kind of storage
network spinning disk and network SSD or
in server SSD and that flexibility it
gives you super high performance if you
want it or lower cost if that's more
preferred but what normal customers do
they find the right balance what
actually do they need for their workload
and they can eliminate the
infrastructure that they don't need and
just save money per second billing right
this is great because you only get paid
for the exact seconds that you use the
infrastructure we also have something
called sustained usage discounts which
is if you just use it for a long period
of time we've automatically deduct up to
30% of your bill and then there's the
benefits of Google Cloud just it's an
end-to-end stack huge data managed
services function as a service
containers and use GPUs any way you want
so here's our portfolio I like to think
of it as small medium and large GPU
right they vary between performance and
price and k80 is the workhorse it's
three generations old it's also the
lowest price in the lowest performance
but it's still much faster than CPUs
that's 12 gigs of memory it's in many
different locations you can get between
one and eight of those in a single VM
one generation newer the Pascal P 100
it's great for compute and visualization
it has more memory 16 gigabytes and it
comes with 1 2 or 4 GPUs per VM and up
to 96 V P V CPUs or 624 system memory
and the brand-new GPU that we just
launched with our team the vault of V
100 and this thing literally is a
supercomputer in a single VM you can get
up to eight of these there s mx3 chipset
it's the V 100 and they come with
special Envy link
pee-yew to GPU communication for HULC
ultra-high performance and this GPU
specifically great for ML workouts due
to its mixed precision it's not just
floating point 64 precision like the
others it also has this mixed floating
point 1630 or - precision that ml really
speeds up so let's look at another
problem
maybe not on Prem but what if I use a
different cloud right and how can I save
money compared to that other cloud for
my GPU workload well I think the best
way to show you this is just another
demo so let's go back to the Google
Cloud console and show you what to do
with this so here I am at the Google
Cloud console I'm gonna go away from
instance groups and just go right to VM
instances I'm gonna create an instance
and let's call this right since I'm a
New York Rangers hockey fan let's say
let's go Rangers GPU one will pick a
location Iowa seems fine US central 1f
and we'll go to the customize field now
maybe in other cloud providers what
you'd have is your CPU and your memory
and your GPU will scale linearly if you
want one P 100 GPU that's same you're
gonna have cores of memory that goes
along with that no option otherwise or
if you want for P 100's with another
provider you'll have to get the cores
and the memory that go along with that
and because of that your price per month
is going to increase this is showing you
4455 per month right for this so the
first way to save money is we get
something called sustained usage
discount so just by using us for a long
period of time for maybe a workload that
keeps going and going not just for one
VM but think of it for the
infrastructure if you use a GPU or VM
for a while you just automatically give
you discounts right up to 30 percent for
that month okay it's this amazing saving
you don't have to do a contract just
save right away so that's one option
another way to save option money on GPU
compute is the customization well let's
say I don't need 62 cores with my 4 GPUs
because maybe my workload does all the
pre-processing it's elsewhere so let's
just bring back down the number of cores
and four hosts memory well you only use
the GPU memory right that's faster it's
quicker you don't need a lot of host
memory so let's bring that down so just
by sliding this down because maybe your
application doesn't need it you save
even more money we took it from roughly
4,300 to 3100 how about another way
let's give you another option to save
money on Google Cloud so we have
something called preemptable VMs and if
I just go down here click on management
there's an option do you want a
printable or not if I say yes
now I'll notice I just saved another
thousand dollars and what a preemptable
VM is Google spare capacity that we
might not be able to sell else buy out
elsewhere if you're willing to use it
with certain limitations you could save
more money so there are a wide range of
areas and how you could save a GPU
instances so let's switch back and tell
you a little bit more about cloud GPUs
so let's double click on preemptable
GPUs I kind of hinted at them just now
and what they are it's a win-win for
everybody
Google cloud might have a little extra
GPU capacity and what we do is we expose
them to you through preemptive GPUs now
there's a limitation right the
limitation is the VM itself can only
last for up to 24 hours and you might
have to take that VM away from you if
someone else needs it but in exchange
for that the CPU and memory will be 80%
off and the GPUs will be 50% off that's
just a clear way to win-win so if you
have a batch workload like a big
training job and you want to save some
money go ahead and create a manage
enza's group say you want a thousand VMs
with v 100 GPUs and if we have the
capacity you'll get it and write your
code let's say tensorflow code to do
automatic checkpointing whereas it's
doing the
it saves the work so that if the VM
comes back online once we have to pass
you just takes over and picks back up so
if you're willing to automate some of
your work you could save some money
through through preemptable GPUs so what
about it being hard to use GPUs well I
guess you know it's harder than using
CPUs it's hard in the sense where you're
gonna write some code or you download an
application and in the code sense maybe
you have to write some new tensorflow
code to say don't you CPU use GPU
intensive load ten takes care of the
rest
or if you have an HPC software just get
it that it's GPU enabled and it will
work right out of the box but what about
Google Cloud what did we do to make it
easier so the first thing we integrate
GPUs across the stack of services so far
I've showed you compute engine about how
getting VMs with GPUs is quick and easy
but there's also integrated with
container engine go ahead and get your
cluster of container enabled kubernetes
engine machines with GPUs and we'll run
your docker or container workloads
through their cloud machine learning
engine right the managed service for
training and inference machine learning
that's also integrated with GPU so you
don't have to deal with the
infrastructure you don't have to deal
with the complexities of building from
source tensorflow and things like that
you just want to run your job so just go
ahead and work in code or data proc
right hey dupe and spark clusters as a
service also give you VMs and
infrastructure with GPUs and you don't
have to worry about the complexities of
managing that and then the fifth service
we've integrated GPUs is Zink singing is
our cloud video broadcasting service
with a wide range of things as far as
transcoding or rendering and it's
powered if you want by GPUs so let's
look at another problem out there let's
say your workload really demands the
highest performance and then you say I
could run CPUs I could run K 80 well
Google has you covered there too we just
launched the Tesla V 100 GPU
this is the latest GPU from Nvidia it
has up to a petaflop of performance in a
single VM right and that petaflop of
performance in one VM comes from eight
GPUs and with mixed precision and this
mixed precision means when you're doing
a math that's maybe not super super
accurate and engineering simulations
need that but machine learning workloads
don't so it's great for that v1 hundreds
also come with envy link and what that
means is we have a special hardware
board where our eight GPUs are connected
together and on that hardware board we
use an abelian 2.0 technology that gives
300 gigabytes per second of bandwidth
between these GPUs so we're away it kind
of creates a system where it it's such
high performance between these GPUs you
could think of a collection of GPUs as
one right you could use more GPU memory
for fast ml and HPC workloads you can
transfer data between these GPUs really
quickly and you'll notice that if you
just scale out by saying give me a
thousand VMs with one GPU each that
definitely gets you done faster but as
you go please give me one VM with envy
link high-speed network with multiple
GPUs the benefits there are even better
we've noticed that up to 40% faster
performance just for your deep learning
machine learning or HPC workloads just
by turning on envied link on the V 100
so it's a super fast super quick GPU and
we just launched it try it out so it's
not just about GPUs right we want you to
pick a little cloud because we want you
to see us as the leaders in
infrastructure we were very early with
skylake CPUs on Google cloud that
literally worked with almost any
workload imaginable right web apps
databases they don't do great on
visualization but they're not meant to
so then if you want to get a little bit
more specific but still generic use GPUs
machine learning HPC video transcoding
movie rending visualization they speed
up all of those workloads and then we
also have the TPU a special chip just
for machine learn
workloads tensorflow the library for
machine learning let's open sourced
works across all of this so we talked a
lot about GPUs in the benefits of google
cloud let's just briefly talk about a
couple of customers that use cloud GPUs
the first one is slumber j slumber j is
one of the leading oil and gas Marisa's
company and as this pictures show one of
the services they do is they have these
sensor units floating in the ocean and
they send a whole bunch of signals down
to the ground and they get a lot of data
sonar or radar a bunch of things and
they just collect that data and they
ship it to Google Cloud Google Cloud
they have a cluster of infrastructure
with NVIDIA GPUs and they process that
data and the end result of processing
that data and doing lots of lots of math
is they're able to create a map and that
map will show them and their customers
right how deep the ocean is where might
there be oil where meant to be
sand and rock and how would you get to
it right and those HPC clusters with
on-demand provisioning versus on-premise
high capital expenditures was one of the
reasons that drove them to Google Cloud
in addition to our security or liability
and our partnership with AI services
moving forward let's look at one more
Shazam
so I'm really really bad at music trivia
when I go camping with my wife and
friends right we'll put that the iPod or
iPad up will shuffle some songs and my
wife will just dominate me in this game
so I love Shazam Sam's an app where if
you hear a song on the radio and you
don't know what it is or at the mall you
pull the app out you hit a button and it
listens to the song it tells you very
quickly what the name and the artist is
unless you listen to it and things like
that and what they do on Google cloud is
they do a lot of data processing right
with GPUs and to make those really quick
predictions of AI heard the song it's
probably this honor it is this song
right they load that information in
databases right on GPUs to give very
quick inference workload results
so in short 99 problems but a cloud GPU
ain't one I hope you get started with
cloud GPU soon all right if you're new
to Google cloud you could sign up get a
free credit $300 and sign yourself up
for some GPUs there's a couple of links
here then the documentation will show
you how to create a GPU with a VM and
then there's also information about
preemptable now we're gonna take a
little break we're gonna find what
questions might be online and come back
with those answers be right back
you
great welcome back so on the list here
we have some questions and we'll just go
through them one at a time so the first
question what's on the roadmap in terms
of new infrastructure hardware and
Google cloud well it's a great question
in general it's going to be what the
customers want right Nvidia keeps
releasing new GPUs we just launched a
v100 they made some announcements of
what might come next
there's always interest on those so as
they've launched new high-end GPUs we'll
probably be bringing those in and also
just like the cloud GPU right we focus
on what workloads are out there and what
other infrastructure and hardware might
we continue to bring in so as customers
demand faster higher price performance
ratios for infrastructure we'll look at
new hardware accelerators
but just like GCE it's not just about
those hardware accelerators we'll also
look at things like what kind of a CPU
memory disk network and you can think of
Google always pushing forward on all of
those second question what type of
workloads are a good fit for the v100
GPU really there's two one that is
machine learning right because of the
mixed precision support and the envy
link connections between the GPUs this
is a very optimal machine learning GPU a
lot of our customers are using these in
large scale to do machine learning
training starting to do some inference
workloads with tensor RT right great for
ml but also just really good for high
demanding HPC wear clothes right if you
really want your results done quickly
and fast right it's a great GPU for that
as well so the next question can you
have both printable and dedicated VMs in
the same cluster another good question
so you can yes in both GCE
and kubernetes engine so on GCE there's
two types of instance groups a managed
instance group and an unmanaged in the
managed instance group we do things like
auto scaling and rolling back code and
with a managed instance group we want
the same type of VM the same shape and
so on and so forth so for that right we
say you has to be the same kind of
template but an unmanaged instance group
right there you can put whatever VM do
you want into a group it can be
dedicated preemptable
and it could you know kind of scale as
you need then the third way is you can
just have two instance groups right you
could have a managed instance group both
management group one dedicated one
preemptable and you could have one
capacity change over time with
availability and the other one always
there and so that's what a lot of our
customers do you want GCE
um kubernetes engine you have something
similar right Cooper dance engine has
the notion of node pools right and you
could have one pool of nodes be
preemptable and another node pool being
dedicated right and you can scale that
side differently as well so both of them
have an option to do it yes let's look
at the next question what would I need
to do to use printable GPUs at large
scales on GCE so with GCE the demo just
showed you that's one way right a
managed instance group you create a
template and you scale up the temp the
instance group to the size you want in
order to get to that there are a couple
things you have to do first you have to
have an account and then you need what's
called quota right quota is a way to
make sure that the customers that are
using capacity are the ones that are the
right customers to use so in that in
some way right so at first you'll have a
small amount of quota and if you really
want to run a cluster of 100 GPUs or a
thousand or even more just go online go
to the quota system and say this is the
amount of the max I want to run make a
submission and we'll get back to you
shortly with what you're allowed to go
up to so those two things dams Insurance
Group and quota will get you that scale
or same thing with kubernetes right got
a criminal's cluster or get some quota
and they can get up and run next
question when should I look at TP use or
GPUs for ML workloads that's another
good question I think both CPUs and GPUs
are gonna be a great fit for ML right
both GPUs are going to be a little bit
more generic kind of work good for all
workloads all libraries tensorflow pipe
torch sky lard carriers with new name
it's gonna work and something to work
for infra it's gonna work for training
cheap use they're gonna be very specific
to the tensorflow for now library and
it's also good for very specific models
and it's going to be really good from a
price
performance perspective for those models
it works so at Google cloud you could
use either we hope you do use the one
you want and you know we'll keep
launching new generations and for better
price performance will keep launching
new features to make it easier and
easier to support ml wear clothes on GCE
and last question are there any plans to
offer AMD GPUs on Google cloud at this
time we just do NVIDIA GPUs but we're
talking to some customers that have
expressed interest so if you have
interest for AMD just reach out